brought to you by the witcher 3 wild
hunt available now hey what's up guess
what there's a new doom coming out and
it's called do straight up going on and
the bow and arrow a joining myself and
Chris on the catch Agee does glad doom
doom doom but that is to put out a
trailer let's check it out let's cut to
the chase so I got this sweet trailer
from bethesda softworks man I hope they
show all the gameplay we can just run
the whole trade ok don't worry about two
shotgun there's a reverend that what ya
doing I'm excited are you excited I
can't wait I hope they do it looks so
jaunty is like oh let's go get a job
when you look at his new ya ya gonna do
so much hands nothing you know that's
true cuz Reverend has 0 rocket launchers
that's true it's just like yeah I think
it's good revenant revenant yes not
Reverend revenant I think that's from
doom to good ol doom it's going back on
old do did you like doing three hundy
barramundi I love dhoom3 love didn't
tweet too much little like you got the
gun out or you got the flashlight out
yes there was a mod where you could get
it was a duct tape mod where they stuck
yeah yeah thank God remember that there
was a hell if anyone as well you know
what i do i turn the flashlight into a
Hello Kitty logo he's really good a
diffuse the tension but it looks like
they're going back to back to the
original sort of hell diminish and
nonsense from the first game and this
one but have you guys seen the trailer
for the unreleased doom game that they
were working on previously oh yeah I
play guitar in that trailer gtq i'm not
sure if we do we have audio on this late
so we do alright we turn it up so this
is an some footage that's just got
leaked by d'un faune slide which is
basically the game that they were making
before and what we now know as doom this
is it looks like quality
thanks rink the division kid looks like
splash damage we're gonna make it deemed
it does it was like we don't like it
more like years Five fries oh yes yeah
maybe the destroyed city that like third
the third person shots of the guy
running into space but this is like
target cinematic feels like there's no
way that that was game yeah like
anywhere near an engine or anything like
that so it's also it's kind of like this
are a tone it turns it yeah own for its
like the mood board of your own trailers
man Tony where's the tone trailer that
just put out is it's the old game
shoulder Jay Z shocking looks like gonna
shanker confirmed I am I on that's
engine I'd like to hear also I like the
logo so you like the minimalist sort of
just flat black on white right nice
little edges so the only this is the
first gameplay we've seen or whatever
this is offices of doom well it like
video a video the gameplay really is jag
leave everything I Brailer they say
exactly that's why I feel like it's not
yeah maybe close but I figured engine
and it's being shot like in camera
apparently they showed gameplay us wait
on boycott that was straight-up gameplay
alright so they're just teasing it was a
weird get all exposed doors you can only
like hellas you were there how is that
not been leaked there was like a
hundreds of people not that's some good
tight they must have been they must have
been like please like you're the
community don't like yeah it's the
bethesda weights the same wood for that
yes I mean the star wars battlefront
game play we saw celebration hasn't been
leaked like it's no big on yourself but
like everything leaks something's just
don't leak yeah it's more like the die
hard you know like you're going to
quakecon you probably been no quite calm
before you don't you know being a person
yeah I mean we all respect our borrows
that were under most of it's mostly just
stretch it a little bit so like you know
people do that yeah but we're gonna see
some more i guess i'm at e3 as doom fans
one and all and what would you guys like
to see id first of all okay here's what
i want to see I want to see all the
footage all the logos and then at the
bottom instead of in software i wanna
see machine games
that would make me so happy because
they're so cool and I made Wolfenstein
so good are you enjoying the the old
blood yeah like a hundred percent yeah
although we'll get to it next but like I
think my perception of shooters is god
dammit ok we'll go finally yeah well but
sounds real good uh you know what I
liked about doom being able to dodge
projectiles hmm like that's not really a
thing you can I mean you could kind of
do that in some shooters these days but
like I'm destiny yeah like that's one
thing like some of the Destiny things
you can see coming and you know it but
like big fireball and you can see
bullets coming at you it's not just a
matter of avoiding you're not just a
you're not avoiding sight lines anymore
you're avoiding actual projectile so you
can be in the sight line you can play
that aggressive way yeah if you can
dodge stuff and if you like our quick
with it so I'd like to see that
excellent I don't think I want to see
apart from some hot bfg action is best
you did a video about explosions sure
incredible video about explosions on
gamespot com the one we forgot to
mention was the exploding barrels in
Doom one when you like it one of those
and the videos were so good it was
sideways you just kind of like exploded
and then if the dude was like within ten
feet he just turned to mulch just like a
disc Rosalynn was so good that's what I
want cuz Wolfenstein they did a good job
of like really making it oh it's just
kind of like crazy over-the-top cartoony
shooter but mom when you shop people it
sucked she was like a shotgun to the
face in that game with real dudes havin
a bad situation I want so like 1080p
alright so you brought up to three
people turning into like bits of
pineapples and poems thicker so let's go
back you brought up dhoom3 right yeah so
that was a change in like the tone of
the game because it was monster closets
and like flashlights shadow management
scares LA because I'm shooting like
arenas kind of with lots of action but
it wasn't so much like a huge area like
serious sam your pain killer which that
was kind of like those were the
spiritual successors to do in a way what
would you want to see do you want to see
a tight corridor directed shooter with
scare
nice tech yes other what you want like I
think the reaction that's just like
crazy Boston Walczak I feel like that's
been done so that's been such
well-trodden ground at this stage like
to me do my know that was like those big
open areas but they were big and open
because they felt big after you spent so
much time being stuck in this line the
complex you know like even the end is
dhoom3 ended up being like outdoor
inhale you know it's just like kind of
like a platform that was penned oh yeah
it was basically stuck from half-life
yeah it does effect as if two games a
bit portals and bad things coming
through aren't already basically the
same story and yeah i don't know i
really like doom 3 but i guess i just
want them to make sure the shooting is
fun i make sure it is like for writing
weapons a variety and bad guys that's
kind of all i care about because one bad
thing about doom 3 was you're basically
up against like imps for the entire game
just is i confident going with fireballs
that's all i'd see cool cool airtel you
just want destiny right yeah pretty much
no i mean like i didn't like now that i
think about it it was like oh yeah dhoom
3 oh yeah it was really dark and he had
to hold the flashlight all the time and
I was like I think I didn't even finish
it cuz like I just couldn't stand it cuz
it's just different I guess from the old
doom so if they do anything from like
the first two I'm good click I'm happy I
want a big an enemy like two stories
enemy like a she like resistance like
just like a huge boss like a kak edema
but it's like it's that big floating
meatball head but it's like the size of
a plane epcot like huge issues well I
knew its mouth so maybe there's like
hearts of it and because then you can
like destroyed parts of it and can get
even more messed up but still come at
you well the way what's a little hang
down thing in your mouth that like wow
oh your tonsils are like a little yeah
that thing that thing is just John
Romero's face I need to like shoot it
and just roll into it yeah actually know
what I want from dhoom 3 as I want
interactive menus that you walk up to
and control the mouse tremor collector
would no no no PDA yeah I'm on my PDA
there was a Nigerian fraud joke in that
game it was a straight-up Nigel yeah
well not anymore but what I get back in
2004 same here half a to commit good
year for games yeah run years waiting 11
years we have a sense of humor but
itself a little bit because
it's kind of dumb oh yeah excellent yeah
well I guess we'll find out more about
in 25 do you think they're gonna stick
with that in tech yet yeah they got it
yep they can't afford to be this is yeah
rage cost a lot of money you make they
got they're gonna make sure this one
this one gets knocked out of a pile
because that's what I got that's it tick
I guess we'll find out soon enough but
see that gameplay reveal at the
electronic triple and at just over a
month's time so make sure you student
stay tuned to gamespot com for all our
coverage at e3